okay five scenarios let's walk through
these five steps one at a time okay ten
spots ten people to fill them with but
five of them are boys and five are
ghosts
okay simple enough right so let's do the
first one the simplest one with whoops
just like the one we just did
you're just a bigger table for a no
restrictions
okay how many ways well I thought you
can think of hmm I will place the first
person place um somewhere anyway you
like one right and then I have nine left
place right so then you multiply by 9
factorial alternatively the first way
you thought about it you are 10 spots 10
things to film with 10 factorial but you
over count it because you can rotate a
whole bunch of them and they're the same
but you get the same answer
anyway I'm not particularly interested
in what 9 factor is equal to more than
the fact that we built it by getting
their factorial your calculator can do
the rest now the conditions begin okay
boys and girls what if we want to
alternate it for maximum boy-girl
problems
okay well if you wanted them to
alternate I start the same way okay I'm
going to place someone and I'm gonna fix
their position now would you like to
pick a boy or a girl a boy of course the
boys there first okay now once you
placed the boy okay let me for instance
put him here okay and don't forget you
know I put him here but I could put him
anywhere and they're all the same so
it's not like oh this one's different to
having you over here same scenario okay
now I have a look this is different to
my first scenario because now I don't
have just have nine people who can sit
anywhere I want think probably that the
the rest of the boys first I've got four
boys left okay but they can't just sit
anywhere can then right for instance
they can't sit here or here or here you
get the idea how many places can they
see
and here too is there are four potential
spots left namely here here yeah okay so
now I have four spots and four boys to
fill them with so how many ways can I do
that well factorial okay and then the
girls come along five spots five ghosts
to fill them with sick will stop all
right see what if what if everyone has
partner boys and girls all matched up
and they want to sit together okay so
they're all in couples right now you can
think about this a couple of different
ways you can think move okay
I'm going to place someone first and
then they'll have to be a specific you
know place a boy then now I have to be a
specific girl next to them and then I've
got a place another specific but it
starts to get confusing very fast okay
so how can we think about this in a
better way that will make this kind of
step really easy right well think about
it like this there are five couples
right five couples and is anyone who has
friends for couples nerves sometimes it
can be very hot some couples of plot in
fact with this situation they are
practically inseparable you actually
can't take them apart right so they
really function as single units right
each couple is a unit okay so therefore
you no longer have five boys and five
girls that you can think of separately
what you really have is five couples
this is the unit that I'm going to place
okay so now let me to buy it off let me
get rid of these boys
your first couple walks up right arm in
arm okay and clearly they're going to
sit together they go to occupy seats
that are next to each other right so for
instance I'm going to place them yeah
there's a couple okay now think the next
couple that comes along right because
all the couples have to sit together a
couple can't sit in these spots over
here can you see that you see why
because then there will be something
that will break the whole couple
arrangement right so therefore the next
color Asia only has a few spots they can
see them they could sit here there's a
potential spot or they can sit here or
you're starting to get the point okay so
what I have is not really a table with
10 chairs actually I have a table with 5
slots for couples does that make sense
5 slots for college okay so here's what
I'm going to do I'm going to place the
first couple now I don't have to worry
about the circular spinning around
rotating thing okay and then I have to
place the other four couples how many
ways are there to arrange for couples
okay but then of course there are more
agents than this right because for
instance let's have a look at that first
couple can we placed right the boy could
sit on the left and the girl could sit
on the right or they could switch okay
now not only can that first couple
switch make an off switch and is their
problems right so here I have how many
ways can I do the boy and the girl
together it's a two factorial right
smooth factorial ways for that couple
and two factorial ways for this couple
and you're starting to get the idea
right so in fact I have under counted by
a factor of two factorial which is just
two ^ well how many couples are there me
it is five so it'll be 32 times 24
whatever
okay